chambéry cinquante cinq mille habitants
portes de l'italie en qui chambre des
sports d'hiver ville qui paie sur le
plan visuel par une célèbre fontaine des
arcades et le château des ducs de savoie
vivre à chambéry c'est y travailler
c'est aussi s'y détendre et s'y
distraire la première troupe permanente
de théâtre et à grenoble 55km l'été
aix-les-bains 13 km propose concerts et
variétés à chambéry même quelques
cinémas de ciné-clubs trois musées on a
vite fait le tour des possibilités pour
une population où comme souvent la
jeunesse domine est-ce suffisant dans ma
foi moi personnellement je dirais que
y'en a pas tellement à part les cinémas
en fachos qui avait tellement dix ans de
distraction vraiment pour les pour les
jeunes on parle par la maison des jeunes
c'est tout ce qu'il ya
moi je pense qu'il ya ces distractions
il ya des cinémas en direct enfin à mon
avis à ceux distraction il ya un musée
une scierie et vous ne vous ennuyez
jamais non non généralement on n'a pas
le temps de ça on n'a pas le temps de
s'ennuyer
vous savez qu'il y as en création ici
projet pour l'implantation d'une maison
de la culture qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
ma foi je pense que ça peut être très
bien au moins chez entièrement pour
wayne aussi c'est si ça peut amener
encore plus de discrétion est obligés
d'être couards
je ne savais pas ma façon cette fois
vraiment très bien
le théâtre municipal de chambéry destiné
à recevoir les tournées parisienne a
depuis 1964 une nouvelle vocation
groupés autour d'un homme monsieur
viraux les chambériens fonde la mcc
association pour une maison de la
culture à chambéry qui avec des moyens
modestes parvient à monter quelques
soirées de qualité concerts des
spectacles classiques ou marivaux et
molière ont une place de choix dans
cette région où la tradition culturelle
vivante qui a donné naissance à charles
dullin à joseph et xavier de maistre le
public qui reprend avec joie le chemin
du théâtre
oui très bien il ya un excellent public
et à chambéry il existait déjà à la base
et nous avons démarré avec 5500 à
lésions et nous espérons bien en avoir
eu 8000 cette année ce qui signifie
quand même d'environ 13% de la
population de chambéry c'est non une
expérience très intéressante
nous n'avons pas d'abonnés ou
d'abonnement nous avons des adhérents
nous délivrons début de saison une carte
d'adhésion et puis le public vient quand
il a envie de venir au théâtre
quelle est la position des pouvoirs
publics la réaction des pouvoirs publics
en votre égard sont très attachés à
l'expérience de chambéry aussi bien sur
le plan ministériel que sur le plan
municipal et nous sommes je pense à
l'avait tout de même d'avoir un
équipement neuf qu'elle est ce qu'elle
sera t'il cet équipement le sépare
encore une fois tout à fait déterminé
mais le ministère suit bien ce mouvement
et la ville ait décidé aussi à faire
quelque chose
la peinture complète la palette de
loisirs savoyard de galerie à chambéry
une autre à conflans
à la galerie d art quatre pattes
reviennent d'exposer rémy martin et o
neal ozouf reda robert perron et
hoffmann
dénominateur commun le figuratif mais
des styles divers
à
rémy martin eto'o est l'enfant du pays
nous l'avons retrouvé dans son atelier
travaillant avec des couleurs fluide
qu'il étale ensuite au couteau
oeuvre très structuré géométriques
élaboré avec une rigoureuse précision
vision personnalisé qui s'attache à l'
équilibre des formes rémy martin eto'o
qui a réalisé pour la promotion de la
savoie une affiche fort réussie occupe
actuellement la première place de la
peinture contemporaine savoyard